[Musique]
Aurélien qui Aurélia qui m'a donc
rejoint sur ce plateau c'est difficile
he de parler vite pour essayer de gagner
quelques minutes pour faire parler nos
invités bonsoir Aurélia bonsir on
parlera beatbox tout à l'heure avec
cette ce championnat européen et pour
l'instant on parle d'une exposition au
Milie VI oui donc l'exposition plastique
plastoc qui a lieu donc au musée de la
ville ce soir ma de marchand donc vous
êtes en charge donc de cette exposition
alors dites-nous quel est l'objectif de
pour nos visiteurs alors l'objectif de
l'exposition plastique plastock c'est
d'explorer la relation un peu
surprenante entre le plastique et le
design des années 50 à nos jours avec la
volonté d'une part de de raconter un P
de l'histoire de 51 Yveline parce queon
est au moment où la ville nouvelle sort
de terre et aussi de bousculer un
certain nombre d'idées reçues à la fois
sur le plastique et sur le design parce
que l'idée sous-jacente c'est de
permettre aux visiteurs de s'interroger
sur le lien qui pourrait unir le
plastique et le design au cours de
l'histoire exactement parce que c'est un
lien qui n'est pas du tout évident quand
on pense plastique on pense pense banale
on pense pas cher on pense jetable
mauvaise qualité et le le design au
contraire c'est le luxe c'est la
créativité donc deux idées qui à priori
ne sont pas compatibles alors
l'exposition se déroule de manière
chronologique c'est ça sur trois étapes
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
ça c'est ça le parcours et chronologique
qui commence juste au lendemain de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale au moment où le
plastique a très mauvaise réputation o
il est utilisé seulement encore pour
imiter d'autres matériaux par exemple
l'ivoire l'anacre l'ébè donc des
matériaux plus nobles voilà des
matériaux beaucoup plus nobles on
utilise pas le plastique en tant que
plastique pour lui-même et
euh à ce moment pendant la la
reconstruction on a besoin de matériaux
nouveaux on a besoin de matériaux pas
chers et c'est là que le plastique fait
son apparition et va devenir le moteur
de la société de consommation oui parce
qu'on est à cette époque aussi dans une
période de consommation de masse
exactement donc le plastique va un peu
révolutionner les modes de vie du
quotidien oui et c'est d'abord pour ça
qu'il est utilisé c'est parce qu'il est
pratique il a et c'est pour ça qu'il
arrive d'abord dans nos cuisines on le
voit bien avec les tuperware qui
naissent à cette époque- làà parce que
le plastique est pratique parce qu'il
est pas cher il est jetable il est
facilement lavable il casse pas il est
résistant donc autant d'atouts qui
séduisent vraiment le consommateur à
cette époque- làà où il y a pas encore
de de phase esthétique puis les années
60 donc là c'est plutôt les designers
finalement qui vont s'en emparer quel
quels sont les apports alors du du
plastique pour ces designers industriels
au début des années 60 les designers ont
envie de bousculer complètement les les
codes établis de rompre avec tout ce qui
avait été fait auparavant et c'est à se
ils se rendent compte à ce moment-là
qu'ils ont à leur disposition une
matière qui leur permet toutes les
audaces qui permet de libérer les formes
qui permet de libérer les couleurs et
libérer aussi toutes leurs envies et ça
donne des résultats assez surprenants
alors aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on peut
encore dire que le plastique qui est
connoté de manière un peu péjorative
est-ce qu'il a on peut encore lui
attribuer cette cette notion ou pas
alors évidemment il y a toujours des
aspects péjoratifs avec le plastique
qu'on peut pas nier le plastique qui
pollue le plastique qui reste éphémère
jetable mais il y a aussi juste
justement on essaie de le montrer à
travers l'exposition toutes ces
nouvelles possibilités qui ont été
prises en charge par les designers qui
ont tout exploré il y a aussi tout ce
versant du plastique qui a tellement
révolutionné nos modes de vie depuis les
années 50 que il faut lui redonner un
peu l'importance qu'il mérite qu'est-ce
qu'on pourra trouver d'insolite ou
d'original qu cette exposition alors par
exemple il y aura des chaises sans pied
celle de Werner Panton il y a une robe
de pacoraban qui est présenté pied elle
repose Suri pied en fait elle n'a pas
quatre pieds elle est en forme de S et
c'est elle est en porte à fau et donc
elle tient par juste le pied à l'avant
c'est grâce au plastique avec les autres
matériaux évidemment faire ça c'est
solide elle tientesser sur le plateau al
oui parce que c'est vrai que les les les
innovations les avancées technologiques
on aussi permis de de de créer des
choses enfin ça le le avec le plastique
on peut tout oser finalement c'est ça et
c'est pour ça que les designers ont tout
fait à partir du début des années 60
parce qu'à ce moment-là le matériau
était au point parce que les procédés de
production aussi ét au point parce que
le plastique c'est très cher à produire
quand on produit que des petites
quantités et au début des années 60 on
sait produire en masse on sait produire
en série ce qui permet aussi le la
diffusion un peu partout dans les
intérieurs et l'avenir alors du
plastique est-ce que on peut lui
souhaiter un bel avenir al il a sans
doute un bel avenir puisque on nous
promet actuellement des plastiques bio
qui seront plus facilement recyclables
alors on dit bio parce qu'ils sont
produits à partir de fibbres de lin ou
de fibbres de chanvre on nous promet
aussi des plastiques intelligents qui
sont capables de réagir à leur ils sont
capables de réagir à leur environnement
alors par exemple c'est déjà en cours de
test ça existe déjà on peut imaginer une
baignoire pour enfant qui réagit à la
température de l'eau en changeant de
couleur qui indique du coup à quel
moment le l'eau est chaude l'eau est pas
assez chaude des brosses à dents aussi
qui changent de couleur quand on a
brossé on s'est brossé les dents pendant
3 minutes alors c'est des plastiques qui
se déformment des plastiques qui voilà
qui réagissent à la couleur c'est ce
qu'on appelle les plastiques intellig
plastiqu intelligents d'accord et alors
cette exposition se veut aussi
participative donc qu'est-ce que les
visiteurs pourront faire alors ils
pourront manipuler ils pourront ouvrir
des placards mais aussi ils pourront
répondre à des questions tout au long
ils pourront participer aussi à des à un
concours d'objet kit notamment parce qu'
évidemment quand on parle d'objets en
plastique on ne peut pas éviter de
penser à certains objets assez kites qui
sont dans nos maisons qu'on n assume pas
forcément mais on propose aux visiteurs
de nous envoyer les photos de des objets
qu'ilestime kitch et le gagnant
remportera un petit lot le choix va être
difficile parce qu'ils sont ass nombreux
ces objets être qui tient finalement on
a déjà de potentiels vainqueurs faudra
venir nous les présenter sur le plateau
c'est vrai que c'est assez assez sympa
et c'est plein de couleurs effectivement
il y a des animations qui sont prévues
aussi autour des expositions en
parallèle oui oui oui il y a tout un
volet d'action culturel donc comme à
chaque fois il y a un parcours qui est
destiné aux familles pour les enfants de
6 à 12 ans qui et aussi à leurs parents
donc après une petite visite dans
l'exposition ils pourront personnaliser
leur siège avec les matériaux plastiques
qu' choisissent au milieu de plein de
formes plein de couleurs et repartir
avec leur création et puis une nouveauté
pour cette année c'est qu'il y a un
parcours spécifiquement dédié aux
adolescents qui est mis en place pour
les 12 18 ans qui s'appelle design et
c'est gagner parce que là aussi il y a
un concours à la fin ça permet à
l'adolescent de se mettre dans la peau
d'un designer de concevoir un objet qui
va révolutionner notre futur et voilà ça
commence ce samedi à 16h il y a la
première séance en accès libre ah oui
puis on peut rappeler que l'exposition
démar aujourd'hui oui l'exposition a
commencé aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 23
décembre jusqu'au 23 décembre ou ça nous
laisse le temps d'y aller oui forcément
on aura le temps aussi d'en reparler sur
cette antenne il y aura un reportage
complet à découvrir lors d' de nos
prochaines éditions voilà nous sommes
un tout petit un dernier mot c'est juste
pour dire qu'il y a une exposition
temporaire en parallèle qui est sur le
mobilier gonflable c'est ça c'est un
petit focus sur les dernières
acquisitions du musée sur un des fonds
les plus importants et originaux du
musée on a reconstitué deux salons
gonflables l'un des années 70 l'un des
années 90 où tout absolument est
gonflable même la plante verte